Can guys please just chill in regards to women?
Uh, with the aggression,
with the way they speak to other guys about women
and the way they would speak to women in general,
not one to usually speak about
the political and economic state of the world right now,
but a lot of girls are feeling very uncomfortable right now
and I think it's uh, my job as a guy to call out to other guys
and I don't think that happens enough
and that needs to start happening.
So when your mates being uncomfortable at the cookout,
at the kick ons, when a friend is messaging in the group chat
telling about the girl they got with on the weekend,
just have a little bit of decorum.
You see enough guys acting like neanderthals in front of girls
when there's people around.
Imagine what's happening behind closed doors.
Can we just chill out, stop being so barbaric and realise we are larger,
we are louder, we can be scary.
So act like that in front of your mates.
But when this girl involved,
just realise how you're coming across
and let's just make things a little bit more pleasant for everyone.
Thank you.